I used Ad Fontes Media
so this is a little more in depth
a lot of people ask me about the media chart I used in yesterday's video
so yeah I know I'm biased, but I try to compensate for it
I've called the Sesame Street for grown ups for a reason
so it becomes easier to take in
and reporting it while being entertaining and simplifying complex things
so my bias is choosing one thing that affects most people
because I can't produce 5 - 10 segments a day on my own pro Bono
I'm doing daily news triage
because I'm not covering every awful thing that happens in the world
a lot of people say that I'm an unbiased news source and I am not
which brings me to - me
even a chart maintained to show media bias will in itself have bias
and if anything that should be the takeaway from this video
and I really don't agree with all this
and they also maintain a separate fact checking bias chart
their main site has a searchable form for more media outlets
and their basic chart is very bare bones without much nuance
another is allsides
I am very guilty of bias through omission
which maintains probably the most in depth bias chart out there
they write on political leaning and news reliability
not many surprises
but I don't get what they call Joe Rogan neutral
but hey it's not my list